i say we start off with the disney story
i think that's the story i want to start
off with okay so we have some comments
did we get anything i see a lot of
people are actually getting it pretty
right
some people are saying some ludicrous
numbers anyways let's have fun with this
let's have fun with this brother when's
the last time we went to disneyland uh
probably three four years ago okay one
more lesson you went through this uh
2016 for senior year easter easter
easter last time we went to disneyland i
want to say three years ago we went to
disneyland with the kids two years ago
something like that three years going
through this
shocking experience good or bad bad
really in what way well they don't have
fast passes anymore or they didn't have
fast passes during the covet protocol
they had limited capacity which was bs
because the place was full
but the you you just sit you sit in
lines you just you went there post
covered during kobe oh dirty easter eggs
oh okay yeah the land or world
here okay we're talking about disney
land right yeah yeah got it you know but
but the fact that you don't have a speed
pass that's a very different experience
when you're used to it at every
amusement park you go to it's not a good
experience without a speed pack they're
not they're not paying me to say it but
universal studios the whole the whole
experience was better just because you
could get you could get the speech
universal is amazing let me let me put
it through this way 10 out of 10 i
prefer universal studios over disney
it's not even close by the way for me i
even have a good time as a parent going
there their disneyland it's fun yeah the
one in la is great too because you know
films have been filmed there you know we
my shonda and i we had a here's how we
did disney
with kids you got to have a strategy
right so we would roll into downtown
disney right because then you could
valet park because i hate the shuttle
there so you valet park slick you go
into the first bar slash restaurant you
see you have a couple shots all right
that's what we did then you can get your
parking validation
by the way it's 10 a.m in downtown
disneyland so you go down there you know
you're you're your kids they're 11 years
old
just the adults right that's the same
and don't say that on international you
know youtube i can see dash being like
that let's go get some shots
you know pops i'm buying today you know
i got you
he's got the money back no kidding i'll
be over with snow white later but let me
hook you up with a little shot right now
um so then we do the disneyland thing
and our reaction after a day at disney
is always this loading the stroller back
into the car you know just dealing with
you just look at each other and go was
that fun i mean you have to go did we
even enjoy ourselves it was disney's a
challenge man it's rough no it's that
remember that show survivor that's like
what it is when you get to the other end
you're like
okay we made it through the whole day of
combat
alive but i have to tell you though for
me
ten hours goes in five minutes one of my
universal studios so weird yeah ten
hours goes in five minutes like this
you're like oh my gosh it's over we're
going home you almost want a little bit
more but because it's it's very
different anyways let's let's let's
again there's a new roller coaster in
the universal studios how's the one in
florida by the way i haven't been to the
one in florida that that's where the new
roller coaster is open have you been to
the wine i've never been to disney world
anybody here been to the one in florida
or no it's not it's insane really i
wrote it i wrote
really universal here in florida amazing
i wonder how much how different it is
than one in california i got to go check
it out and see it's um it's faster
you've got more interesting rides here
good thing here here okay cool all right
so let's get right into it so disney
uh uh in 2008 disneyland ticket cost 41
a price hike just increased it
ready
264 okay that's a 4x increase is what
we're talking about okay disney
announced monday that it's adding a six
level to his tier ticket price system a
level that becomes available when
there's a high demand at parks the six
tier will set you back 164 dollars for a
single day single park ticket if you
want the ability to visit both parks in
a single day you'll need to pay 224. a
tier 6 is set to go into effect in march
of 2022 in 2000 a single ticket to this
inline cost 41
adjust it to inflation ready folks that
ticket would only be 62 today so disney
the the inflation they're living by is a
completely different they're living by
venezuela type of inflation that's what
they're doing tiers two through five are
also going up tier two previously 114
they're going 119
tier 3 from 124 to 134 tier 4 from 139
to 140 now tier 5 from 154 to 159 the
first tier will remain at 109 but only
applies to lowest demand days generally
weekdays in slower months like february
parking has also increased effective
immediately used to cost 25 a day to
park in the main lots now it's 30
dollars time i'm going to go to you sure
okay so i think it's interesting you got
to look at what type of revenue does
disney draw from the theme parks for the
whole company it's almost 40 percent and
you know that that thing 40 40 it's 37
or 38 almost 40. so you know that tank
during covid right so they have to get
that back here's another interesting
fact the guy who replaced bob iger was
the president of the theme parks so
there's going to be an there's going to
be a you know a priority
yeah for sure without a doubt now here's
the problem
disney has become so woke right and and
their characters have changed and i
think if you're not looking for that
type of environment if you want to go to
disneyland just to get away to have that
magical california experience that it
was known for since walt disney opened
up those gates how many years ago that
was part of the magic and the charm of
california you go there everybody
remembers their first time to disneyland
it's a slice of americana it's as good
as america gets you have nothing to
worry about in there you forget about
everything and then you leave and and
resume your life so when newsome shut
down the economy that hammered all those
other small businesses in anaheim around
disneyland so it's a compound thing so
seventy eight thousand jobs lost by the
world it's so sad it's so tragic i mean
these people that their whole livelihood
depended on disney and for years they
could count on it and then they couldn't
so you've got them trying to make up for
lost time for not having and get disney
was shut down for a year disney world
was open probably eight months before
disneyland
so it's a huge difference it's sad i
don't i'm glad my kids are old enough
where they don't want to go anymore they
would much rather go to universal dash
went to six flags last week for the big
halloween fun thing so disney's kind of
out of it for me and it's really i feel
like it's another thing that we've lost
in this whole transformation that we've
gone through as a country in the last
year or two well think about think about
a whole generation of grandparents that
aren't going to go with their grandkids
who went with their kids because of the
wokeness i mean
i'm sorry but you grew up with fairy
tales you don't change a fairy tale a
fairy tale's a fairy tale you don't
alter the characters you don't say you
can't kiss sleeping beauty no uh-uh
because there wasn't consent are you
kidding me it's sleeping beauty you
cannot alter a fairy tale you can't kiss
sleeping beauty no no because it's not
consensual remember that story that's
just
kai since you are the closest to
understanding the
you know the
ideas of this nominee and you're you're
on both sides
pat kai had mouse ears on three years
ago okay
matter of fact in his job interview he
had a mickey mouse shirt but tell us
tell us about this disney story i
thought that was gonna be between you
and i yeah uh no i think this is this is
crazy and he brings up a good point with
covid and that it's been closed and
stuff like that but
in the grand scheme of things i don't
think that changes things all too much
because in that case they wouldn't have
still raised the prices by a hundred
bucks but from 2000 so in those 20 years
nothing major like covet happened during
that time so you can't really just blame
it on kovit being it i think it's just
more that they're continuously
hiking up the prices because they can
they know that people will come and i'm
sure they've done the the cost benefit
analysis of seeing how much will we lose
if we do this versus how much will we
like make extra and but i think the
biggest thing for me as well is just the
plus plus plus plus plus i know when
we'd go there we'd be there all day we'd
come in the morning and we'd leave after
the fireworks at midnight yep and
obviously at that point you need like
two meals it's now parking went up and
there's the snacks and there's all the
other stuff there's 17 chicken nuggets
yeah so it's that to me blows my mind
even more of just there's so much more
that's just plus it's a thousand dollars
for foreign fair numbers to put easily
because then they put the disney store
right you have to walk by it fifteen
hundred four yeah you're right
right yeah they're fair it's it's all a
profit machine sense like at that point
if it's one of those if it's if you walk
in and everything's an upsell then why
are you also being charged that much
initially but i'll flip i'll go i'll go
a different angle as well so here's
here's the other angle i call when when
uh when uh jack dorsey tweets out
hyperinflation is coming to the states
and the world and people lose their
minds what are you talking about uh this
is hyperinflation so whatever you wanna
do this is a sign of when people say no
it's not coming this is hyperinflation
and this leads to the story with
thanksgiving right when you're talking
abiding inflation with thanksgiving but
let let's down disney for two more
seconds because i just i want to put my
wonk cat on for two seconds and be dorky
and be geeky
this decision was made in the shadow of
the third stimulus check being sent out
to americans when they felt like they
had all this extra cash that they were
flushed with that they could run out and
take this big vacation so that's what
management based this decision on
there's no more stimulus checks coming
i'm just saying they might not have the
audience that they think they have you
think so they might not i mean how many
american families can afford what you
just said 1500 for a minimum for it this
also doesn't include
if it's somebody like us that would have
to travel there this is assuming you're
just driving up and you're parking there
part of me loves this
let me explain to you why i love this
i'm going to tell you why i love this
majority of people that go to disneyland
what what wealth bracket are they are
they on is it low income middle income
or world i agree okay perfect guess who
has the biggest voting power in america
the silent majority okay and the middle
right so the middle is going to go and
they're going to say what the hell is
going on then they're going to say maybe
this inflation conversation isn't
[ __ ] maybe this concept of
constantly printing money and sending
people money to people maybe it doesn't
work and now we're feeling it so there's
a part of me likes the fact that this
disney thing can become a social
experiment for families to say pump the
brakes we ain't going to disneyland how
much are the tickets are you out of your
mind there's no way in the world and
then they're going to say you know what
i think we need to stop kind of just
printing money to have this you know and
the other thing too is if they're going
to jack the prices up to this level it
you know if you have a couple kids
disneyland if you live in southern
california is a must thing that you have
to go x amount of times i want to have a
problem at 1 500 if it was a great day
but if you end up spending this kind of
money and it's not the same and you're a
little offended and then it's it's too
politically correct and you're annoyed
over here then you're thinking what the
hell i'll never come back here again
what a waste of your time and money
because i think with that as well is is
people are willing to pay a higher price
if you're getting a better experience
for it but if you're paying just to pay
and you can't have fast passes and
you're standing in line all the time and
all this other stuff anyways then that's
more where i see the discrepancies
way more than it's worth the other part
when you're doing a business like let's
just say they had two major new shows or
new things that they built or a new
experience and then you announce this
guess what i'm going to say okay cool
fair enough i'll come because i'm going
to test out the new viper the new
superman the new whatever thing right
the new star wars thing here in orlando
and at disneyland it was the star wars
thing that was the basically a couple
years ago yeah well what i'm saying is
today like if you're doing something
today to increase it like this
you got to kind of give the audience
you're making it better here's why you
want to come because we just announced a
adult
and the kids this and this then maybe
but just you just do it like they guys
we're raising the prices yeah okay
that's not how this works but it works
because
so many things are tied to each other
and the american people today have to
sit there and say listen
let's reconsider how we vote we have to
pay a guy yesterday uh yesterday bernie
sanders tweeted something he says three
words tax the wealthy
i retweeted at him and i said three
words you are wealthy
look in the mirror
then a guy says but you don't understand
bernie never said he has a problem not
paying the taxes you know even if he
increases it he doesn't want paying
those taxes i said oh really is that why
when he was going on his campaign trail
he was not paying his employees the 15
minimum he was paying them less than 15
minimum but he was telling everybody
else to pay 15 minimum so the hypocrisy
eventually shows up in your finances and
how you spend your money so yes i mean
these ideas of people just imposing the
pain on others eventually you're going
to feel it yourself as well you know i
would just say this about disneyland one
of the best things about it for me was i
hate roller coasters i could go on it's
a small world and kill a good 45 minutes
to an hour where i wouldn't have to be
brought onto a stupid roller coaster i
hate them so this is stupid i'm probably
i'm probably the only person that likes
it's a small world you know you hear
that song the whole time yeah i know you
you you know there's nothing then it
stays in your brain the whole day you
really look like you're struggling with
there's an emotional challenge going
with you in disney and some roller
coasters what did you experience on the
road you had a bad experience can't you
be afraid of heights i am afraid of
heights are you really oh my god get me
on a ski lift i almost freak out
i am 100 serious i cannot i cannot deal
well listen we were just going to say we
were inviting you and shonda to aspen to
go skiing together and and maybe these
this just got canceled
i'll be the guy in the lodge all day
in the hot tub
having his shots for breakfast
you got to work on
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you